paul was sagst du wie wird dieses beben
dieser kurzschluss in österreich
besprochen wie wird es aufgenommen
es ist ein absolutes beben was hier
passiert ist das stimmt jeder in wien in
österreich spricht darüber sebastian
kurz ist der prominenteste politiker des
landes ja was ist passiert gestern muss
man sagen war die medien lage am morgen
vorher in große kritik an sebastian kurz
dass er weiter bleiben wollte dass er
nicht den weg frei machen wollte die
grünen hatten ihm ein ultimatum gesetzt
und was dann passiert ist es sehr
spannend ein echter polit krimi der sich
da am wochenende abgespielt hat wie wir
hören freitagnacht bis den samstagmorgen
hinein hat sebastian kurz gespräche mit
seinen engsten vertrauten geführt hat
gespräche darüber geführt wie kann es
noch weitergehen nachdem herr kogler der
grünen chef gesagt hat er will nicht
mehr ja und dann ging es in den samstag
hinein da gab es gespräche mit den
landeshauptleuten und irgendwann hat
sebastian kurz dann ja gesagt okay wir
machen eine andere lösung wir schicken
alexander schallenberg vor der bisherige
außenminister er soll den kanzler job
übernehmen aber sebastian kurz tritt vom
kanzleramt zurück aber das bedeutet
nicht dass er seine politkarriere
aufgibt er will weiter vp chef bleiben
und klubobmann bleiben und das bedeutete
am ende bestimmt er hier als eine art
schatten kanzler weiterhin die politik
also auch eine konstellation die es so
in europa hat von noch nicht gegeben hat
paul du stehst gerade da vorm kanzleramt
in wien und bist du nicht irgendein
reporter der dann nach österreich
gefahren ist sondern du kennst sebastian
kurz sehr gut und sehr lange das ist
einmal über dieses menschliche drama
auch sprechen mich wenn ich mit 35
jahren ex-kanzler jetzt zumindest
erstmal ex-kanzler was weißt du im
moment wo steckt sebastian kurz zur
stunde und wie hat er selbst diese
stunden des rücktritts aufgenommen
sebastian kurz ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht hier hinter mir im
kanzleramt soweit ich weiß ist er zu
hause in meidling ein arbeiterstadtteil
seine freundin erwartet in den nächsten
monaten ein kind also auch privat
passiert einiges bei ihm und man kann
sagen sebastian kurz will aber trotzdem
weiter kämpfen hat momentan keine
interviews gegeben ich habe gehört
gestern hat er noch eine rede gehalten
vor seinen mitarbeitern hier im
kanzleramt und wie ich höre von leuten
die dabei waren sie sagen er war
weiterhin kämpferisch hat er die anderen
aufgebaut und was sie sehen bei
sebastian kurz trotz dieser schweren
vorwürfe die da von der
staatsanwaltschaft kommen trotz dieser
vorwürfe sagt er er will das jetzt
aufklären und dann will er weitermachen
kann und ich habe hier jemanden
stehen der wie kein anderer die wie
keine andere sebastian kurz nämlich
kennt eli köstinger ministerin
landwirtschafts und tourismusministerin
und engste vertraute mit von sebastian
kurz vor köstinger was bedeutet das
jetzt für sebastian kurz auch persönlich
was da passiert ist zum einen hat er
wieder seine große bewiesen und hat aus
staatspolitischer verantwortung
seine person hin angestellt und hat das
amt zurückgelegt nachdem in den letzten
tagen durchaus auch der
koalitionspartner sich sehr stark auch
in ein eck gebracht hat also spezielle
grünen haben ja auch überlegt herbert
kickl von seiten der fpö in die
regierung zu nehmen nur um kanzler kurz
zu stürzen und für uns als volkspartei
als team rund um sebastian kurz geht es
um das ganz große ganze es wäre für uns
nicht möglich gewesen das land jetzt dem
chaos zu überlassen und deswegen jetzt
auch dieser entschluss und dieser
rückzug des nationalrats in den club und
damit ins parlament aber vor kurzem hat
das ja nicht freiwillig passiert es gab
diese schweren vorwürfen es gibt diese
schweren vorwürfe von der
staatsanwaltschaft da geht es um betrug
und korruption das sind ja dinge die
dort erst mal auf dem papier stehen also
wie setzen sie sich jetzt auch als vp
und auch als sebastian kurz mit diesen
vorwürfen auseinander ich glaube das
muss man ganz klar voneinander trennen
da wird aktuell sehr viel miteinander
vermischt dass eines der strafrechtlich
relevante und das zweite ist was
vielleicht klappt's manchmal daher
geschrieben wird für jeden bürger in
diesem land muss die unschuldsvermutung
gelten auch für den bundeskanzler er
wird jetzt die möglichkeit haben das
aufzuklären ich wünsche mir von der
justiz ein schnelles verfahren wir
erleben dass sie in österreich dass das
sich zum teil über jahre hinzieht und
das zweite ist die rolle der volksbank
und nachdem jedoch auch schon sehr viele
jahrzehnte in dieser partei mit dabei
bin und arbeite es ist noch nie eine so
große geschlossenheit hinter einem
partei obmann gewesen wie in den letzten
tagen die landeshauptleute haben sich
ganz klar für ihn ausgesprochen
das gesamte regierung team der
bundesregierung hat sich geschlossen
hinter hingestellt und damit werden wir
eben auch herz weiterarbeiten und doch
gab es erhebliche kritik auch in den
österreichischen medien wenn man
samstags hier die medien angeschaut hat
von profil krone alle haben gesagt so
geht es nicht weiter sebastian kurz muss
zurücktreten
ist das jetzt das endgültige politische
ende als kanzler oder haben sie
tatsächlich das gefühl dass er nochmal
zurückkommen kann naja ist ja weitere
partei obmann der volkspartei in
österreich er ist gewählt das heißt er
geht jetzt in den nationalrat übernimmt
dort die funktion des klubobmanns und
wird natürlich auch weiterhin
wichtig die geschicke der volkspartei
und damit des landes auch leiten wann
wird es neuwahlen geben oder wird
alexander schallenberg den man
vielleicht den deutschen zuschauern noch
mal erklären muss der war mitarbeiter
besonders dann kurz dann außenminister
in der übergangsregierung dann nochmal
außenminister und jetzt kanzler wird der
jetzt möglicherweise für viele jahre
hier in dieser koalition im kanzleramt
bleiben oder rechnen sie damit dass es
dann eine neuwahl gibt wo sebastian kurz
wieder antreten könnte also wir ist
volkspartei wollen keine neuwahl wir
haben die korona pandemie zu bekämpfen
den wirtschaftlichen aufschwung wieder
zu gestalten im aktuell gott die größte
steuerreform in der geschichte
österreichs ausverhandelt auch das war
ein grund das land über über die person
zu stellen um wirklich für spürbare
entlastung für den menschen zu sagen
ich gehe davon aus dass die grünen jetzt
wieder zur vernunft kommen dass wir
gemeinsam weiterarbeiten
das ist das was sich die menschen in dem
land erwarten sie sind eine enge
vertraute von sebastian kurz sie waren
generalsekretär innenministerin in jeder
regierung sie haben immer an seiner
seite gekämpft was wissen sie wie es ihm
jetzt persönlich geht in diesen stunden
nachdem er schon zum zweiten mal als
kanzler zurücktreten musste zunächst
nach der ibiza affäre wo es um heinz
christian strache ging und jetzt schon
wieder was macht das mit einem mensch
der jetzt 36 ist schon zum zweiten mal
oder 35 zum zweiten mal altkanzler
bereit also ich glaube es ist menschlich
sehr nachvollziehbar dass das nicht
spurlos an einem vorüber geht vor allem
wenn man weiß dass man sich nichts zu
schulden hat kommen lassen wenn man weiß
dass die vorwürfe die im raum stehen
sehr konstruiert sind und es muss eben
auch die möglichkeit geben das zu
widerlegen du willst sebastian kurz
alles rechtlich alles politische das in
seiner macht steht auch in anspruch
nehmen um das zu tun das ist richtig und
das ist gut so sein team steht an seiner
seite und ich bin überzeugt davon dass
wir uns auch wieder zurückkämpfen letzte
fragen vorchristlicher dennoch sie sagen
das alles nichts dran die vorwürfe sind
haltlos noch einmal die
staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt also in zweifeln einmal wegen
falschaussage das zweite mal eben wegen
dieser betrugsvorwürfe und bei diesen
chats kommen immer wieder neue
nachrichten ans tageslicht als von
zehntausenden hunderttausende
nachrichten die rede die da ausgewertet
werden von der staatsanwaltschaft aber
was bleibt da haften also wenn man sich
diese schätze anschaut dann ist das ja
schon eine sprache die man nicht lesen
und hören will von politikern also ich
glaube jeder der dieses politische
geschehen in österreich verfolgt hat hat
miterlebt wie seit 2017 seit dem ersten
antreten von sebastian kurz es für alle
anderen nur ein programm gegeben hat und
das war kurz muss weg inhaltlich wird in
österreich relativ wenig diskutiert wenn
diskutiert wird dann immer um die person
von sebastian kurz und das gibt führt
jetzt hat natürlich auch in vielen der
medialen darstellungen also spezielle
oppositionsparteien und leider auch der
regierungspartner hat sich die abwahl
aus dem amt vor sebastian kurz als das
erklärte ziel
gesteckt das ist meiner meinung nach zu
wenig für ein land und das ist auch
nicht das was sich die menschen in dem
land erwarten deswegen werden wir weiter
arbeiten werden wir alles dafür tun dass
es funktioniert dass die menschen arbeit
haben dass wir weiter eines der
schönsten länder der welt sind und
gemeinsam werden wir auch uns mit
sebastian kurz zurückkämpfen herzlichen
da eigentlich erst dinger ministerin für
tourismus und landwirtschaft hier in
österreich engste vertraute mit von
sebastian kurz und man muss sagen sie
wurden auch als kanzlerin gehandelt sind
sie enttäuscht dass es nicht geworden
sind das konnte ich immer ausschließen
herzlichen dank vor köstinger kaida das
mit hier einem exklusiven eindruck von
forstinger auch direkt vor dem
kanzleramt sie war in den nachtstunden
in den tag stunden immer dabei als hier
die entscheidungen getroffen wurden und
sie wird dabei bleiben wenn es jetzt um
alles geht nämlich um die frage wie kann
man mit den grünen weiterregieren und
vor allem wie geht es dann auch weiter
mit sebastian kurz
[Musik]